let's see what this guy has right here
he's a young guy who's obviously been
dealing with something right here
i know him andrew and theo gang gang
buzz buzz what up
chappelle nick chin give me that cat
hitter
got a debate club for you guys i think
this is a real good one
who's the best dancer black guys
or girls or asians
oh bad guys chappelle versus chin
get it going why don't we just do gang
gang buzz buzz can you dance
i mean we can play some music you guys
want to dance right here we already know
who won this battle
wow i don't think we know that well
jabba walkies though like koreans can
dance
bts bts but chin isn't one of those
that's like 12 koreans there's a
k-pop is huge and then [ __ ]
dance dance i was given different gifts
not dancing i can't move my body like
jabba wackies what do you think
cat how many are you talking about chin
and chappelle or black people versus
asians i think black people naturally
dance better but asians if they trapped
us
then yeah if they have like choreography
they kind of train
than them i think naturally black people
just kind of
black people have rhythm they have
rhythm they have uh asians have work
ethic
they're gonna beat them into those pop
block and drama and different dances too
because
break dancing i would say asians all
skyrocketed
thank you yeah rock and roll too culture
culture vultures
did black people teach korean people how
to dance
culture vultures when though where no
or some koreans probably like when
breakdancing like
first popped off they probably looked at
it was like damn that's kind of dope
yeah inspired
it just like evolved and i think they
just took it to another like
level like culture i could maybe see
some of that i just don't know if there
was like a
ship of korean people that went to
africa and
talked about that's happening with
chinese people right now in africa
yeah apparently the biggest like
interracial couple over in africa right
now
are uh the chinese and africans that's
hot damn
so there's a lot of boys can you google
that nick chinese african couples
hot there's a lot who's ablazion who's
the famous karuchi
tiger woods tyga tiger woods part
vietnamese
um the rapper yeah he his mom is half
enemies half black
but that dick all black
you ain't on the only fans account then
of tiger
you would know he's packing heat yeah
holy fan's account yeah yeah
he put his big old dangling pick on
there no way they put his whole he put
his full ding-a-ling on
it and it's good
see i didn't say that kind of [ __ ] yeah
but it's worse just not yeah but you eat
a spicy chip you're gonna start saying
different things
yeah look i ain't taking you to prison
home
oh benson henderson yep
vincent henderson we just talked to him
nah
what he's a fighter right he's a uh
rival of michael chandler's oh yes oh
bruno mars
i don't think he's black though no bruno
mars he's puerto rican and filipino yeah
yeah
that will demps guy he's like super
handsome all the girls i knew
he was a safety for the baltimore i mean
he's that's a lot that's awesome yeah
that's an old-school reference
but he's good looking hyde's ward was
sweet again
old school oh man
fat as [ __ ] now dawg he was always kind
of thick right
yeah he's blessed best blocking wide
receiver of all time
all right
[Laughter]
there's a girl right now her name is
joyce rice black and korean she's
gorgeous joyce rice joyce rice what's
she look like
you can google it imagine it bro
come on down dang the price is right
yeah
the price how's that not a game show huh
whose rice is it anyways you feel me no
you're not feeling that
no that's not that good the price is
rice is better nah it's too easy
whose rice is it anyways dude that's a
show about starvation
no they gotta fight for food
yeah i think that's the hunger games no
the price is
right come on down brendan who is the
one you said
karuchi she's so cute someone that date
chris brown
okay she's dating uh she's got shot in
the court didn't she no no
no that's meg it's karuchi k
a u r tim mix belt coochie
h there we go kuruchi triumph yeah
you better educate yourself nick
she's modest um
she thought it up you keep going yeah
she thought it
she's pretty modest she's out of
afghanistan huh
yeah she's pretty man she was she was
nick uh chris brown's girl forever but
she's
dating she's with cruz yeah tom cruise
no victor cruz
who's that retired yeah retired giants
receiver
yeah first team all zaddy well
well well who's rice is it anyways
the price is right